Although he's best remembered for his contributions
to sci-fi television as creator of Star Trek,
many of Gene Roddenberry's show concepts never
got off the ground.
After his death in 1991, his widow Majel Barrett
discovered a stash of Roddenberry's scripts
and notes for some of these proposed shows—one
of which became Sci-Fi Channel's hit series,
Andromeda.
With over 100 episodes wrapping up over a
decade ago in 2005, here's what the stars
of Andromeda are up to today!
Kevin Sorbo
As one of the elite High Guard of the Systems
Commonwealth, Kevin Sorbo's Captain Dylan
Hunt and his starship Andromeda Ascendant
were responsible for protecting the planets
and inhabitants of three galaxies, until his
leap 300 years into the future.
After the series ended, Sorbo, who was previously
best known for playing Hercules, continued
building upon his prolific acting career with
appearances in The O.C., Meet the Spartans,
and many other films and TV shows.
Additionally, Sorbo lent his voice to several
video game characters in titles like Skylanders:
SuperChargers, and has reprised his role as
Hercules in the God of War game franchise.
Most recently, you can spot Sorbo in Supergirl.
Lisa Ryder
Lisa Ryder's Beka Valentine had never been
interested in saving the galaxy—until she
crossed paths with Captain Dylan Hunt, and
she became a loyal member and First Officer
of the Andromeda crew.
These days, the Canadian-born Ryder is still
working as an actress.
She's appeared in over a dozen different roles
in TV and film — most recently, Nurse Greenwood
in the FX horror series The Strain.
Additionally, Ryder has returned to theatre
where she got her start.
Her play Wild Oxen was featured in a workshop
reading during the 2017 Groundswell Festival
in Toronto.
Laura Bertram
At the start of the series, the purple-skinned
humanoid alien Trance Gemini—played by Canadian
actress Laura Bertram—had a bubbly and effusive
personality, only later transforming to reveal
her true nature.
Since the end of the series, Bertram has enjoyed
a successful acting career.
You may have spotted her in guest roles on
the popular shows Supernatural and Once Upon
a Time, or in her recurring role on the Hallmark
Channel's When Calls The Heart.
Additionally, Bertram is a high school teacher
in British Columbia, as well as an instructor
at Biz Studio screen-acting school in Vancouver.
Gordon Michael Woolvett
After the fall of the Commonwealth, Boston-born
Seamus Harper, played by Gordon Michael Woolvett,
escaped from the Nietzscheans, and eventually
ended up as a crewman for Valentine.
Woolvett has since appeared on Supernatural,
the Canadian drama The Guard, and the CW horror-comedy
series, iZombie.
Woolvett is also comfortable behind the camera
as a director, as evidenced by his 2017 documentary
Around the World in 80 Anthems.
Lexa Doig
Known affectionately by the crew as "Rommie,"
the android avatar of the powerful artificial
intelligence within the ship Andromeda Ascendant
was portrayed by Toronto native Alexandra
Doig.
Following her stint on Andromeda, Doig has
continued to work on several sci-fi TV shows,
including Supernatural, Stargate SG-1, V,
and Continuum.
Fans may remember her from the 2002 horror
film Jason X.
Most recently, Doig appeared on Arrow as well
as The Arrangement.
Keith Hamilton Cobb
Among the Andromeda crew, ruthless Nietzschean
mercenary Keith Hamilton Cobb's Tyr Anasazi
was a fascinatingly complicated character
to pin down.
Cobb left the series after the fourth season,
and immediately transitioned into his role
as Damon Porter on The Young and the Restless.
Cobb then moved on to Logo's Noah's Arc, and
CSI: Miami.
In recent years, Cobb has returned to the
theatre, penned a number of short stories
and other written works, and is currently
touring his one man show, American Moor.
Steve Bacic
Nietzschean weapons officer Telemachus Rhade,
played by Steve Bacic, was a latecomer to
the Andromeda crew, having joined Captain
Dylan Hunt in season two.
Following his spot on the series, Bacic continued
in his career with Hallmark's All for Love,
Blade: The Series, The Guard, and HBO's Big
Love.
Most recently, he reunited with Lexa Doig,
in an episode of Arrow.
Brandy Ledford
The android Doyle, played by Brandy Ledford,
debuted on the show when she was built by
Seamus Harper while he was stranded with a
malfunctioning Rommie.
After the series, former model Ledford appeared
on Canadian mystery drama Whistler, Stargate:
Atlantis, Modern Family, and NCIS: Los Angeles.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!